herzlich willkommen zurück auf meinem
kanal wir werden heute kräuterpflanzen
egal ob das die kräuter sind die ich mir
jetzt hier ausgesucht habe oder
vielleicht auch ganz andere
ich zeige euch jetzt wie ihr für jedes
kraut in eurem garten wachsen könnte was
ihr vielleicht anbauen wollt den
richtigen platz bestimmt und euro beete
perfekt vorbereitet sodass ihr
hoffentlich ganz bald ganz viele leckere
kräuter stiftung so auch für heilkräuter
erteilt reuter in ihrem garten erben
könnte
[Musik]
das hier ist es beten dass sich die
kräuter pflanzen möchte und zwar
allesamt obwohl die ganz
unterschiedliche ansprüche haben
direkt daneben den hühnern raluca hund
das und ich zeige euch jetzt liegt er so
vorbereite und so einteilen dass alle
kräuter trotzdem glücklich sind und zwar
ist das ein was hier auf der seite
den ganzen tag war sie in der sonne
liegt das ist ja für viele kräuter super
gut aber es gibt auch einige kräuter die
lieber im schatten wachsen und hier
diese seite ist sehr sehr schattig
gekriegt nur ein paar sonnenstunden am
tag das werde ich mir eine zunutze
machen ich habe mir hier kräuter
ausgesucht für euch die extra ganz
unterschiedliche ansprüche haben
und da kann man bei allen kräuter in
drei sachen unterscheiden es gibt
kräuter die sehr gerne in der sonne
wachsen und es gibt kräuter die er
lieber ein bisschen schatten haben nicht
komplett fertig also ein paar
sonnenstunden am tag sollten die alle
bekommen aber es gibt welche die im
halbschatten sehr zufrieden sind also
das ist die erste unter scheidungsgrund
lage werden gibt es kräuter die sehr
gerne auf einem sandigen und trockenem
boden wachsen und es gibt kräuter die in
unseren kompost beten super zurecht
kommen und damit sehr sehr glücklich
sind wir legen unsere beete feste das
noch nicht weist mit kompost an da kann
ich euch auch mal ein video hier oben
verlinken oder ihr kommt in mein mini
kurs da zeige ich euch nämlich wie man
diese beete an legt der ist kostenlos
den link packe ich gerne in die video
beschreibung also entweder die kräuter
mögen sonne oder halbschatten oder sie
mögen die kompost beete oder auch
normale gartenerde oder eher sandige hre
beete und die dritte möglichkeit kräuter
so ein bisschen einzuteilen ist ob sie
es eher feucht mögen oder eher trocken
das heißt ob sie eher ab und zu gegossen
werden wollen und wenn man sich alle
kräuter so anschaut dann kann man die in
drei große gruppen einteilen und das
hilft einem dabei den perfekten standort
für sie zu finden
das ist einmal gruppe 1 die ganz heißen
das sind diejenigen die gerne in der
sonne wachsen in der prallen sonne
die sandigen boden mögen und die kaum
gegossen werden wollen oder überhaupt
nicht gegossen werden wollen weiß ich es
gerne sehr sehr trocken haben
da sind vor allem die mediterranen
kräuter dann gibt es welche die auch
gerne in der
sonne wachsen aber auf kompost beten
sehr gut wachsen und die keinen sand
eingearbeitet wollen in ihre beete das
sind die heißen hungrig dann gibt es
welche die sgr feucht und halbschattigen
mögen die coolen so habe ich das mal für
euch eingeteilt und damit ihr jetzt wenn
ihr kräuterpflanzen wollte genau wissen
welche dieser kategorien eure kräuter
denn fallen habe ich euch eine liste
erstellt wo wir alle kräuter eingeordnet
haben die uns eingefallen sind ich hoffe
wir haben alle gedacht
in diese drei kategorien denn wir werden
jetzt hier unser beet in drei
abteilungen teilen und die kräuter so
pflanzen dass alle glücklich sind obwohl
sie auf ein und demselben beige wachsen
also hier ist wieder unser bett und ich
habe euch ja schon erzählt dass in der
ecke da schattig ist und deswegen ist es
der perfekte ort für die coolen das ist
die ecke hier gilt es immer immer
sonniger und deswegen kommt ihr gruppe 2
hin heiß und hungrig ich hoffe man kann
es lesen da also hier unsere zone 3 zone
2 und hier vorne in der prallen sonne
wollen die ganz heißen wachsen und die
stehen ja auf einen sandigen boden
deswegen werden wir jetzt erstmal sand
ranschaffen und den ein bisschen dort
ein arbeiten wo unsere kräuter später
wachsen sollen
[Musik]
da kommen wir zu den hauptdarstellern
dieses streifens hier in der kategorie
so hat die ganz heißen habe ich einmal
einen thymian und einen bohnenkraut die
wollen es beide gerne sonntag sonnig und
trocken
dann haben wir bei den heißen hungrigen
nur einen kandidaten das ist ein majoran
der kommt also gut in den kompost bieten
hier zurecht oder auch in normaler
gartenerde ohne dass man die mit sand
anreichert und die ganz coolen sind
gleich drei
da haben wir einen kümmel eine schoko
minze schmidt übrigens super lecker nach
after eight richtig geiles zeug und hier
eine hugo minze
das sind meine kandidaten die werde ich
jetzt hier schön am weg entlang pflanzen
und so hat jeder genau den standort der
ihm gerecht wird hier drüben ist es
wirklich sehr schattig und in die
richtung wird es dann immer sonniger und
bei den dreien hier weiß ich die freuen
sich mal ab und zu über ein bisschen
ließ wasser da hinten muss man dann
nachdem sie angewachsen sind überhaupt
nicht mehr gießen
[Musik]
wenn ihr eure kräuterpflanzen dann
natürlich erst mal gründlich angießen
und ein trick bei allen pflanzen die ihr
neue pflanzt ist dass ihr da rundherum
so eine art dies kragen macht ich weiß
gar nicht ob man das auf der kamera so
gut sehen kann aber ich schichte immer
rund um die neu gepflanzten pflanzen
eine art wahl auf so dass wenn man die
pflanzen gießt das gießwasser auch da
bleibt wo es hin soll und in den ersten
wochen müsst ihr die frisch gepflanzten
kräuter natürlich immer noch schön
gießen bis sie dann richtig angewachsen
sind so fertigt das ganze könnt ihr
natürlich auch auf eine kräuterschnecke
oder kräuterspirale übertragen je
nachdem ob eine seite vielleicht mehr in
der sonne liegt und eine mehr im
schatten ansonsten wenn ihr nur ein sehr
sonniges beet habt dann sucht einfach da
für die sonnen liebenden kräuter aus und
pflanzt die anderen in ein anderes bild
das könnt ihr sicher sehr gut auf euren
garten übertragen in der tabelle habe
ich euch auch die richtigen trends ab
stände für alle kräuter mit
zusammengefasst also ladet euch die
gerne unter der link ist wie gesagt
unten in der video beschreibung da
drüben findet ihr ein video in dem ich
euch zeige wie ihr kräuter durch
stecklinge vermehren könnt und da unten
ist auch noch ein spannendes video für
euch vielleicht sehen wir uns ja da
wieder
ich freue mich auf jeden fall ab nächste
woche mit einem neuen video bis dann
mach's gut